father oh uh my son Thor has
returns greetings my
boy it's a interesting play what's it
called the traged of Loki of ascar
people wanted to commemorate him indeed
they should oh I like the statue a lot
better looking than he was when he was
alive though a little little less weasly
less greasy
maybe do you know what this is oh the
oferta that's a formidable weapon do me
a favor lock this away in the vault so
it doesn't turn into a giant monster and
destroy the whole
planet thank you dear um so it's um back
to midgard for you is it nope you know
I've been having this reoccurring dream
lately every night I see Asgard falling
to ruins that's just a silly dream
scientif with an overactive imagination
possibly but then I decide to go out
there and investigate and what do I find
but the nine realms compl completely in
chaos enemies of Asgard assembling
plotting our demise all while you Odin
the protector of those nine Realms are
sitting here in your bathrobe eating
grapes yes well it is best to respect
our neighbors Freedom yes of course the
freedom to be
Massac yes besides I've been rather busy
myself watching theater well board
meetings and Security Council meetings
really going to make me do it do
what you know that nothing will stop me
on here as it returns to my hand not
even your face you got quite mad you
you'll be executed for this and I'll see
you on the other side
brother all right I
he
behold Odin
son
you had one jum just the
one where's Odin you just couldn't stay
away could you everything was fine
without you Asgard was prospering you've
ruined everything awesome where's father
did you kill him you have what you
wanted you had the independence you
asked for ow ow okay I know exactly
where he
is